Speaker 1: We have kind of an interesting
little wrinkle or substory in the January
6th Trump riots.
We know, of course, about hundreds of defendants
whose cases are now somewhere in the legal
system and going through.
We've started to see some of the first sentences
several weeks ago.
We saw some of the first sentences for the
Trump rioters who were charged.
We now have another prominent individual who
has been charged.
This is this is actually quite interesting.
Many of you remember Infowars.
This is Alex Jones conspiracy website.
Their content is banned from a number of different
mainstream platforms, including YouTube, I
think Facebook.
I don't remember the whole list.
I think they're banned from Spotify.
But the show continues.
Funding comes from suppliments.
And I think from Mike Pillow and maybe a couple
of other brands, you have to really look pretty
hard for the show.
But it is out there.
And one of their hosts is a guy named Owen
Shroyer.
He has been charged and reportedly is turning
himself in today.
This is a Reuters report which says U.S. prosecutors
have charged a Texas man.
Who hosts a talk show tied to the conspiracy
theory website Infowars with unlawfully breaching
the U.S. Capitol grounds during the January
six riot by supporters of then-President Donald
Trump, Olwyn Shroyer unlawfully entered a
restricted area at the west side of the Capitol
during the deadly rampage that interrupted
the formal congressional certification of
Biden's victory.
This is based on what prosecutors wrote in
unsealed court papers from Friday.
The hosts he hosts a talk show associated
with Infowars called The War Room with Owen
Shroyer.
It's a daily show.
These are misdemeanor charges, violent entry
and disorderly conduct on Capitol grounds.
Let's look at video here of Owen Shroyer explaining
this.
This he learned this apparently from his lawyer
during a live broadcast on Friday.
Take a look at this.
The deal.
Speaker 6: Ladies and gentlemen, yeah, a couple
hours ago.
I was informed by my attorney very serious.
But there is a warrant out for my arrest.
With allegations involving January 6th.
And I will have to turn myself in Monday morning
today.
There's a lot of questions, some of the answers
to some I don't.
I'm not going to be getting into more of this
today on the air.
Smart.
And.
I plan on.
Declaring innocence of these charges, right,
because I am and so there's some other stuff
going on, too.
But that's the deal.
Oh, boy.
And so I'm not going to I'm not going to comment
any further on this.
I'm not going to take any questions on this
today.
Speaker 1: But the questions thing, do they
even take questions on this show, like who's
going to force them to answer questions on
this show?
Speaker 6: And I was informed by my lawyer
that there's a warrant out for my arrest right
now and that I have to turn myself in by Monday
morning.
So that's just that.
Probably shouldn't even be on air right now,
but we're going to go ahead and do a broadcast
anyway.
Speaker 1: OK, and that's probably the correct
instinct.
He probably should not be on the air if this
is if this is what is going on.
So there's only Shroyer.
Another relatively high profile target of
the investigation has turned up multiple alleged
charges against them.
And we'll follow it.
These are misdemeanor charges.
It is less likely he will do prison time.
It is more likely he has better access to
lawyers, particularly if Alex Jones is going
to help him out.
But on Shroyer turning himself in as far as
he
is
saying
he
will
do today,